for many this was a moment to save her
at exactly midday people all over the
netherlands flock to outdoor terraces to
toes the easing of restrictions
they are now allowed to open in the
afternoon until 6 pm
although social distancing measures
remain in place
we were just telling each other it now
looks like kovit does not exist
everything seems normal again of course
we know about the hospital admissions
but if you look around you might forget
about it
guests have to book in advance and are
only asked to wear a face mask when they
go inside to use the restroom
although business owners are happy they
have mixed feelings
we hear reports from the hospitals so
i'm aware of what's going on
we are not the ones who have made these
decisions but
at the end i think this is better than
people who are sitting and standing
close to each other in the streets
thousands of people violated covet
restrictions on tuesday when the
netherlands celebrated the birthday of
king willem alexander
dozens were arrested spirologists and
medical workers have called easing
restrictions
dangerous and irresponsible but many
here in the netherlands couldn't wait to
go back to some kind of normalcy
their excitement is a strong contrast
with a dire situation in dutch hospitals
with infections as high as during the
first wave doctors are warning
icu capacity is reaching its limit of
1350 bets
if that happens a so-called code black
may be issued
and hospitals would have to choose who
gets treated
maybe you are now in code black already
because
we keep the patients home we send
patients home too early
i think the quality of care is
diminishing former head inspector of
health williams halligan says the
government has been playing with fire
trying to control the spread of the
virus and taking a risk
hospitals will no longer cope we have to
diminish the infection rate that is that
is obligatory
and what is the government doing easing
the restrictions
and that's contradictory that's
contradictory i can't understand that
he predicts that the easing of
restrictions will only prolong the covet
crisis and will possibly force the
government to impose a much stricter
lockdown after all
in the next few months not a message
these people enjoying a drink in the sun
want to hear step farsen al jazeera
utrecht